It is time for it to come to an end.
"Chaos" is the word I think many
people in San Francisco would use to
describe the situation.
It's homelessness problem has been
out of control for years.
But COVID made it even worse.
Is shoplifting happening every
single day?
Every single day, any time they
want.
Residents here are mortified.
We're beyond wit's end.
It comes to an end
when we take the steps
to be more aggressive with
law enforcement and less tolerant
of all the bullshit that has
destroyed our city.
On December 17th, 2021,
San Francisco Mayor London Breed
declared a state of emergency in the
city's Tenderloin district, which
will lead to an increased police
presence in the epicenter of the
city's growing homelessness and
addiction crisis.
It was a major turnaround for Breed,
who, after the murder of George
Floyd in 2020, called for
ending the use of police in
responding to non-criminal activity.
And she was roundly criticized by
progressive politicians and groups
like the Coalition on Homelessness,
who called the move an expansion of
strategies that have been tried and
failed that would contribute to the
instability and poor public health
outcomes of people living on the
streets. Michael Shellenberger,
author of the new book San
Fransicko: Why Progressives
Ruined Cities, calls Breed's
new tough love approach a big step
in the right direction.
The homelessness crisis, he says, is
actually an addiction and mental
health crisis enabled by progressive
policies that permit open air
drug scenes on public property,
prevent police from enforcing crimes
and undermine the creation of a
functional mental health system.
Reason spoke with Shellenberger, a
Bay Area activist best known for
his advocacy of nuclear power,
about his foray into social policy.
His critiques of both progressive
and libertarian politics, mayor
Breed's new approach and how he
thinks America's big cities can
clean up their streets without
grossly violating civil liberties.
So your new book is
San Fransicko: Why Progressives
Ruined Cities.
First off, can we talk about the
title for a second?
It's a little aggressive, no.
Are you worried about scaring off
potentially persuadable people?
I do worry about that.
I don't want to scare off anybody,
but I also believe in truth in
advertising, and the title
is accurate.
You know, the basic argument of the
book is that San Francisco and
other liberal cities are sick.
They have untreated
they have people with untreated
mental illness and untreated
addiction.
Camping in parks, on
sidewalks, using drugs, publicly
defecating publicly.
It's a huge health
public health problem,
and I don't just mean homelessness.
I mean the broader, you
know, urban decay
and including rising crime.
I also think I also argue that
there's a kind of
sick way of thinking about
these problems, which is to
pathologize and to
view the world as and
to view the, you know, our system,
as you know, fundamentally
evil and wrong and that that
leads to terrible outcomes.
You know, the book is not it is
about San Francisco, but it's also
really about what the subtitle says,
which is why progressives ruin
cities.
It was a question I had and and
and still am asking, but try to
get to the bottom of which is why is
it that cities that ostensibly
care the most about
poor people, minorities,
people suffering mental illness and
addiction. Why do they treat them so
terribly?
What's going on is the issue of
money. Is that a lack of housing?
Is it a lack of rehab?
What's going on?
That's the that's the reason for the
book.
I'm curious
about your journey
to this topic because
you're kind of known as the nuclear
guy. That's how I knew you.
But there is sort of a through line
here. I mean, you came
from progressive politics
in the environmental movement and
started to question some of that
in terms of whether it was actually
achieving its goal.
Now you've expanded your focus to
urban dysfunction more generally.
Is there some sort of connection
there or did
were there other reasons that you
decided to expand your focus?
Yeah, for sure.
And I'm still a nuclear guy, and I'm
still working on energy, the
environment, I still write about it
and I still campaigned to support
nuclear. In fact,
our nuclear work is really
more salient than ever because we're
in a global energy crisis because
of in part because of lack of
nuclear and also the lack of natural
gas, which is also fuel that I
support.
So, yeah, there is, and it took I
had to actually write the book to
see some of the connections, but for
me and the third book
also coming from the same publisher
Harper Collins,
probably next year
and there will be three, there'll
be three books Apocalypse Never, San
Francisco, and then the third book.
And they're all dealing with this
issue of really
the threats to civilization from
within the civilization.
Like, why is it that we're having
serious problems of governance?
Why is it that our institutions are
failing?
And you know, the most dramatic,
I think example of really
the progressive attack on
institutions is
when I was reading about the effort
to shut down psychiatric hospitals,
which had a bunch of problems and
needed it to be reformed.
But nonetheless, they were shut down
and this kind of panic
without having adequate places for
people to go or requiring people to
be there.
It reminded me a lot of
the panic of shutting down nuclear
plants and and I keep seeing
it over and over again.
And in fact, Greta Thunberg the
climate activist.
Her most famous line is "I don't
want you to have hope, I want you to
panic." Which I was
very critical of in Apocalypse
Never, panic literally means
unthinking behavior and
action, which is not something we
should wish on our worst enemies.
And I see myself making the
case for civilization.
And that sounds a little grandiose,
but but certainly making
the case for institutions
that you have to have that
civilization is cities
sort of literally what it meant.
But those cities depend on
institutions, and it means that you
need to have police and you need to
have criminal justice and you need
to have functioning electricity
grids and you need to have homeless
shelters. And
so you need all these things.
And and there's something that
happens when kind of the radical
left really muscles
liberals and Democrats into taking
some pretty radical actions, and it
certainly happened on the right too.
I'm not suggesting it doesn't.
But but I see I see that as the
through line in the work,
The perspective that you bring to
this as a former activist
involved in progressive causes.
I have to say it's oddly relatable
to me because progressive
politics and libertarian politics
overlap in many of these very
areas: drug legalization,
criminal justice reform,
the rights of those with mental
illness.
Yet as a recently
former Californian who has
seen and documented and
experienced a lot of
the tragedy unfolding on the
streets, I've had to personally
think very deeply about
how some of these policies have been
implemented and their real
world effects.
You know, I still want to see major
changes in laws and sentencing
across the country that maximize
personal liberty.
But my general sense and
it was bolstered by
a lot of what you dug
into in the book here, is
that the way it's been implemented
in practice
has emphasized the personal
liberty side of the equation
while ignoring the personal
responsibilities part and
for a libertarian.
Those things are bound
together.
What is your big
picture diagnosis of what's gone
wrong in California cities?
Yeah, thank you for that and I
totally agree with you.
I mean, I love my freedom and I'm in
San Francisco. I'm in the I'm in
Berkeley, which is across the bay
from San Francisco. I'm in
California because I love the
cultural libertarianism here.
I love the fact that we
really reject a lot of the
traditional statist hierarchy of
the East Coast around where you went
to school and working in big,
you know, companies and stuff like
that. I love the entrepreneurialism.
I just think that's the most special
part of the of the of the left
coast.
So I totally agree.
I also care a lot about people.
I mean, I think the libertarians
lay down people is that they care
about freedom more.
And the trip that progressives lay
on people is that they care more.
They're more compassionate and
there's probably some truth to it.
But I think the truth is that I
think a lot of us love our freedom
and a lot of us care a lot about
other people. And we're looking for,
particularly now, I think, some
practical ways to solve
these problems.
So I mean, I view the problem
out here. I view there's
a lot of things going on.
But if you kind of take the
so-called homeless problem,
I believe that is fundamentally a
problem of untreated mental illness
and drug addiction.
Drug addiction, I believe, is a form
of mental illness.
I also think I agree that it's often
self-inflicted and sometimes
it comes from trauma, sometimes it
comes from undiagnosed depression or
anxiety, or even more severely
schizophrenia.
But sometimes it just comes from
partying too much.
I mean, addiction is just something
that afflicts a bunch of people,
and it's untreated.
I agree, though, that we don't have
a functioning psychiatric system
that really helps people to get
themselves like a lot of people that
are addicted to hard drugs might
have just done fine with an
antidepressant and some cognitive
behavioral therapy and exercise,
which works for almost everybody.
So. We don't we don't have that,
and that's the the traditional
progressive criticisms, we don't
have that, but we do need that.
And then the other issue is just, of
course, that why are there so many
people on the streets in San
Francisco and California?
It's because we let them.
It's there's a myth that it's
because of the weather.
Certainly in freezing places
like Chicago, it's hard to be on the
streets year-round.
But there's other places like Miami,
Miami, which are warm, which don't
have the same problems that we have.
Or least they did, and then they
fixed them.
And I think there's been some
backsliding, but nonetheless has had
much better outcomes than we have.
So it's sometimes it's easier to
describe what the solution is and
then work through why we're not
doing it. And the solution is
basically a universal shelter.
I think that the Supreme Court has
established it, but even regardless,
the Supreme Court, ethically,
we should one that everybody should
have a safe and clean place to
sleep.
It should not be so nice that it
attracts people who want to stay
there, but that should be universal.
That's not the policy we have.
We have a Housing First policy
rather than a shelter first policy
under this utopian idea that we can
just provide everybody who wants
their own apartment in San Francisco
or Venice Beach with their own
apartment. It's obviously wrong.
Just geographically, you can't do
it, but financially you can't do it,
and it creates a terrible incentive
for people to become homeless.
We need to enforce laws,
including misdemeanors, including
against a public campaign, including
against public defecation and public
drug use.
Those are cries for help from
people, and when they break those
laws, they should be arrested,
brought before a judge and given the
opportunity to have rehab or
psychiatric care rather than
jail or prison.
There's nothing super extraordinary
about where I come to
philosophically, but I do
sort of point out that the core
American value has been freedom
ever since our founding, and that's
a beautiful value and wish to
continue to have that value.
But it does require responsibility
at the individual level, but
also at the societal level
and really that we need to balance
those two values responsibility
and freedom.
I know from reading your book
that you don't want to go back
to the bad old days of
insane asylums and mass
incarceration, total
drug war, but
also the current trajectory
in these cities is clearly
not right, either.
What is the middle path forward
from here? The synthesis?
And how do you think that those of
us who are legitimately concerned
about these issues, like personal
liberty and autonomy and
not bringing in heavy handed
law enforcement to
bother people for, you know,
sitting on a park bench with
their stuff or something
can be part of a
productive coalition to get
America's cities
back on track for the 21st century.
Yeah, well, it's a great question.
I sort of boiled it down to the
three key Ps,
so we don't want overincarceration.
That means that we need to rely more
heavily on good policing,
on psychiatry and
probation.
And I would just include in
psychiatry, rehab
and addiction care.
And I would just add to that you
also need some kind of caseworker.
You need some empowered caseworkers
or assertive case management is
what's called to bridge
those things. So, you
know, one of the big arguments for
defunding the cops as we say
"Well, the cops shouldn't be
responding to mental health calls.
We should have social workers do
that. Well, it sounds good.
But actually less than 10 percent
of those mental health calls
are safe enough for a social worker
alone. I mean, a lot of those mental
health calls are really scary and
involve people engaged in violent
activities.
And so really, what you want is
to you want more
soft cops and more
hard social workers and you want
them working together.
And it sounds very kumbaya,
and in some extent it is, but it's
not easy, and it does take
the police department's changing.
And then that's why I think you do
need something like cal psych.
So homelessness is
the kind of umbrella issue
under which many other sub
categories fall.
And you mentioned mental
illness, drug use, and we'll get
into those a little bit more in a
second. But there's also
the issue of housing, which
I would say in the book you very
much downplay and say,
you know, housing prices really are
not a major driver of
homelessness.
I mean, there is some empirical
research out there that at least
shows correlations between
local rents, local
housing prices and,
you know, incomes and rates of
homelessness.
So first, just taking
the housing plank here,
isn't it at least plausible to you
that that some subset of
the population here are
people who maybe were right on the
margins, they got displaced.
Being out of your home
can exacerbate various
underlying mental health conditions,
and so is making the
problem worse.
Is that a plausible story
to you?
Those camps that you see,
the so-called homeless encampments,
it's just a 100 percent addiction
and mental illness.
I'm not saying there's not somebody
there who has been off drugs for a
little bit or suffering mental
illness, but there's some underlying
sickness there that is leading them
to be there.
There are then
now now could housing, could higher
housing prices
worsen that situation?
Absolutely. I mean, so for example,
the classic picture is
somebody becomes addicted to, let's
say, you know, somebody a
20 year old is addicted to hard
drugs. He's still living with his
parents.
He stops working.
He starts stealing from
his parents and lying
to them. They try to get him into
rehab.
Then maybe he goes, It doesn't work,
doesn't stick. Finally, they just
cut him off and they kick him out.
He then goes and lives in a homeless
encampment on the street.
I think that that moment of kicking
somebody out probably occurs
much more quickly
and maybe occurs when you're living
in a much more crowded conditions
and much more expensive rent
areas. So I can totally see
that. The difference, though, is
that do you allow
the open public campaign?
So for example, if it were just a
function of high rents,
then we would see homeless
encampments in Beverly Hills
and in really nice neighborhoods.
But they're not. They're always in
the same places near train stations,
near public transport downtowns,
in poor neighborhoods,
often minority communities.
And so, you know, ultimately, I also
allude to this issue of the magnet
effect. There's always, you know,
policymakers are always saying that
because you offer social services
or free housing or food and shelter
that it attracts homeless people
from around the country.
I definitely found a lot of evidence
for it.
But at the end of the day, I was
like, people are attracted to the
open drug scene in San Francisco
and in Los Angeles and there in
there in the open drug scene
is allowed to exist
because progressive activists,
really radical left activists, but
certainly after the rebranding of
the 1990s occurred.
Progressive activists have
said that it's immoral to
disallow public camping, that
it's criminalizing poverty and
homelessness, and that it must be
allowed and that only things can
be given and nothing, nothing taken.
So I don't want to suggest there's
no role for high rents, but in
some of the most interesting studies
where they were a site where
scholars looked at this.
You're right, they did find a
correlation.
But they also noted that
in the places where you have high
amounts of unsheltered homelessness
tend to be very progressive cities.
They didn't quite use the language,
but cities where they had different
social values.
So, you know, people's attitudes
towards the homeless or towards the
street addicts are different in
Houston and Dallas than they are
in San Francisco and Seattle.
There's this ideology
called Housing First, which you
mentioned earlier, and
it's really the operating assumption
of most homelessness policy
in all these cities, even at the
national level, at all the
large nonprofits, which is that
just get people under
a roof in their own
private space, and that
will begin to fix the problem
and turn things around.
And it sounds very clean
and intuitive,
and there's a certain simplicity
to it that's very appealing.
From covering it in L.A., I
know that it's not workable,
at least in a city like Los Angeles,
where the economic reality
of building these units has caused
them to go up, you know, above half
a million dollars per unit in some
cases. Why doesn't housing
first solve homelessness?
What's not working here?
The basic reason is that if you go
get people with untreated mental
illness and addiction in their own
apartments and you don't deal with
the untreated mental illness or
addiction, they actually do end
up back on the street, often very
quickly.
We now know from a big Harvard study
that was done over 12 years that
there was no better.
There was no better outcomes for
people that had a housing first, the
non housing first, even on their own
metric of keeping people in housing.
That is the only metric that they've
been able to boast of success, but
we have seen no evidence.
The National Academies of Science,
which is our premier research body,
did a review of the science.
I think a couple of years ago, maybe
twenty eighteen, and they found that
Housing First did not have any
improved outcomes and that there was
some evidence that it had
worse outcomes because
they didn't deal with the underlying
problem of addiction and mental
illness there.
The response, just to be fair to my
opponents on this, their response
is they said, "Well, we never said
that you wouldn't also have
services." So I tell a story
in the book about my
Dutch character is a social worker
and how he dealt with a man with
schizophrenia.
Very serious schizophrenia.
The original housing first idea, by
the way, came from you using
that strategy with people with
mental illness, not addiction.
And there was a lot of similarities,
but there's also a lot of
differences,
particularly with things like
schizophrenia and drug addiction.
But my
character, his name is Renee.
He he tells a story of basically
kind of muscling.
A friend of the family who had
schizophrenia into
first some shelters, then into
psychiatric hospitals a couple of
times, and then he finally got
them on good meds.
And the guy now has his own job, his
own apartment, his own car.
And for schizophrenia, that's just
an extraordinarily positive outcome.
I mean, he tells a story about a guy
still has hallucinations
and delusions. He thought people
were staring at him through his
window, and Renee's like, just
close the curtains.
You know, that's a
beautiful outcome.
And I think that is what they're
the best of the housing first people
wanted. And they stressed, they said
you'd have services in that case
would be Renee or somebody
to be playing that role.
But that's just not what's been
occurring. And some of that isn't
the fault of progressives.
It's because we don't have a
functioning psychiatric and
addiction care services.
But a lot of it is also victim
ideology, which is a
weirdly libertarian
part of it. You know, which is sort
of like just it's liberal,
left libertarian, a kind of
anarchist libertarian, which is sort
of like you, they're victims
of trauma and racism and poverty
and whatever and addiction and
almost give them the means.
You should give them things like
their own apartment and offer them
help, but don't require
it. Don't mandate it, because that
would be an extension of the
victimization.
And that's where everything goes
wrong. I mean, addiction,
particularly focus on addiction for
a second, but even schizophrenia,
there is some amount of coercion
that's usually required for people
to quit their addiction.
People do need to be arrested or in
Portugal.
They do these interventions
with a kind of mix of family
members, social workers, you know,
government officials and cops.
But still, it's pressure on
people and we know this about
addiction. We have a whole reality
TV show called Intervention.
That shouldn't be so surprising, but
I think there's that's where the
dogma has interrupted
the proper treatment of people with
addiction and mental illnesses and
actually requiring some amount of
pressure or coercion.
There's this kind of zero sum game
and competing for funds between
shelters and permanent
supportive housing.
You know, for every one person
permanent supportive housing unit,
you could build, you know, tons of
beds in a shelter,
you know, in addition to the
economics of scale there,
that with the shelter model,
you can still implement this
sort of reward system where
you can work your way up from the
shelter to, you know, a private
room to your own place.
Is that the appeal of shelters?
There is still a role for, I think,
publicly subsidized housing, again
that's something we can talk about
in terms of the libertarian concerns
about it. I think it should be
limited.
I think the goal should be
independence, which I think
everybody should share for people to
the extent that that's possible.
I mean, truly disabled people,
obviously, that's not possible.
And so one of the things that
I would see the social workers do
in the Netherlands is they would
offer people their own private room
as an incentive or eventually
maybe their own apartment if you can
afford it or if you have that.
But even their own room is a really
good incentive for people because
people don't like sharing rooms
and people don't like congregation
spaces
everybody is the same in that way.
And so that housing
earned approach we had there was big
studies done on this in
Birmingham, Alabama, actually
clean on crack and they would find
that crack addicts who
were given their own
apartment as a reward for
passing a drug test and being off
cocaine did very
well. It actually, I mean, it's
still, you know, it's not perfect.
But but it did much better than the
Housing First, folks, when
they had some sort of an incentive
to change their behavior.
I want to talk to you about
the drug war, which I still see
as a giant failure and think
that decriminalization and
eventually legalization is the right
path forward to alleviate
a lot of the suffering we see on the
streets and sidewalks, though
maybe done in a perhaps more careful
way than it's been done in some of
these cities.
You say in the book that you were
once a critic of the drug war.
Do you still think it's a good idea?
You know, given what we know about
the effects of the black market,
people having their lives ruined
with jail or prison time
is keeping drugs
criminalized a viable path
forward.
So I mean, I think if you kind of go
to the drug war, succeed or fail,
well, on the one hand, it's
obviously spectacularly failed
on every level because we
have 100,000 people that died from
drugs last year.
That's an increase from 17,000
in the year 2,000.
I mean, it's just the numbers are
mind blowing.
You know, that's three times more
people dying of drugs than car
accidents, five times more dying
than from a homicides.
So number one cause of death right
now for people between the ages
of 18 and 45.
So, you know, these are terrible
numbers.
I want to be careful, though,
because I think that I think
that I mean, what I'll say is, I
think we are we are I think we are
evolving and I hope that San
Fransicko is a part of it.
I believe it is a part of the
evolution of our thinking,
which had traditionally been
just decriminalized drugs
or your or a prosecuter
and you want to lock them up.
I think there is a third way, and
that's I. hesitate to use that word
because
it's been so kind of contaminated,
but basically, I do think that
there's a better way, which is much
more similar to the Dutch and
the Portuguese model, although the
Portuguese have much tighter family
and community networks, so it's a
little bit harder to replicate.
But nonetheless the Dutch model,
they are putting pressure on addicts
to quit.
At the same time, if you're using
heroin, cocaine in the privacy
of your own home and you're not
camping on the streets.
There's no they're
not going to go after you and
they're really not going in after
you hear either.
And in terms of drug dealing,
drug dealing continues
in the Netherlands and it continues
all over the world.
And I don't think you can get rid of
it. Or I would say, I don't think
you could get rid of drug dealing or
drug use without a severe
curtailment of our civil liberties,
which nobody, not even
the most fascist really in our
society would support.
But you can disallow
open drug scenes, which
is the homeless encampments.
You can disallow open air drug
dealing.
It's hard, but it is.
We do know how to do it, which is
that you basically suppress
any, you know, if you see one
dealer and one addict making
a sale on the street, it's not a
priority for police.
But once it becomes known,
and part of the problem is that like
addicts, if you live in Cleveland,
like you know that San Francisco is
a place that you can go to and use
heroin openly and freely on a low
cost.
And so when you shut that open-air
drug scene down an open
drug dealing down, it massively
improves the security of the
neighborhoods.
I mean, I think I can get behind the
idea of cities
prohibiting these open
air drug scenes on public property.
I think you could make that case on
libertarian grounds even.
Where it gets dicey
is with this issue of
personal consumption,
even, you know, selling to people
within the privacy of your own
home or some private venue.
Is that somewhere?
And Portugal, for
the record, actually, they
they will arrest you just for
doing drugs and bring you in front
of a drug court and then kind
of force you into rehab.
But are you willing to, you know,
kind of draw a bright line there and
say, you know, let's just focus
on the open air drug scenes
and not going after
casual drug users?
Yeah, absolutely, I'm very
comfortable with that.
And I think actually being explicit
about it and creating some societal
consensus is an important
step in solving this problem.
In fact, it's the first step, in
fact, that study I mentioned about
saying the open drug scenes they
actually created like a like a list
of things that all the studies did
in the first one is established in
the social, societal and political
consensus. And they all said he did
that because if you don't do that,
forget about it.
So, yeah, absolutely.
I still I am very
uncomfortable with the government
getting involved in selling these
drugs or selling them from
pharmacies. I do still think
they should be.
I think I think it's okay to
decriminalize decriminalization
is different than legalization.
Yes.
And so I think it
should be hard to get those
substances. Not easy.
But I'm sure you are aware
of the research.
You know, we've had this opioid
crisis with with pain pills
and in areas where
they crack down on the pain pills,
people turn to the illicit street
drugs and the overdoses go up.
So isn't there ultimately
even a case for saying,
you know, just allow the legal sale
of all of it and we need to
build up a safety net
around it? We need to build build up
appropriate treatment centers.
And to your point, you know,
put recovery up
there, as you know, one of the top
priorities and kind of learn
to grapple with the reality
of these drugs in a kind of
more sophisticated manner society
wide.
Again I look to the Europeans
because they're ahead of us on this.
They had the open drug schemes in
the late 80s. They made the same
mistake that we are making now.
They changed their approach.
They involved law enforcement in the
early 90s, and they fixed it.
There are supervised
drug use
sites in the Netherlands.
There's about 20.
I just got the research I haven't
published yet, but my my character
gave me that information.
There's about 20 supervised drug use
sites in the Netherlands.
They get between 10 and 20 people
per day, and it's a tiny
number of people, if you think about
it. There are some
people that they do give
heroin to in the in
the Netherlands, it's about 100.
It's less than 150.
Those are people for whom methadone,
which is the substitute for heroin,
did not work.
Suboxone or buprenorphine
is a superior or somewhat
superior. People think to methadone
is widely available.
So I am.
I'm on board with the Dutch model.
I'm fine if you need to have some
folks to allow
them to use those harder drugs.
But but they do not sell
heroin or fentanyl in
coffee shops in the same way that
they do marijuana.
Yeah, I will say
I continue to
think that the evidence points
towards when you criminalize
these substances, they tend to get
more dangerous.
However, you did raise this
Dutch model with some
activists this idea of
offering an alternative to
jail treatment as an alternative
to jail.
And I was kind of surprised that so
many activists
just said no, that that
is not where
we're going with this.
We're not even talking about someone
who's been arrested just
for possession and somebody who's
been doing breaking the law
in some other way.
And instead of sending you to jail,
we can see you have an addiction.
So we're going to divert you to
treatment.
Were you surprised at the pushback
to that idea?
I was.
I was. Annoyed.
I find myself still annoyed
by it because
that was not my understanding.
Now, maybe I back in the 90s.
I mean, and now maybe I
misremembered it.
Or maybe I.
But I feel a little hoodwinked that
there was this idea that
we were going to. We were going to
have rehab as the alternative to
prison.
But then when it came time to
implement these things,
I think it was also just a thing on
the left.
I mean, maybe the right to, but I
know the left better, which is that
like, you kind of get a little bit
and you keep pushing.
I think they had just so much
political power that progressives
were just like, Well, we don't want
to require anything like that.
And I think that that plays into
victim ideologies.
So, yeah, I was bothered by
it.
I mean, just even at like a kind of
political level, you'd kind of go,
Well, wouldn't that be progress?
Like, wouldn't that like if you're
trying to legalize all drugs
and you're like in a conservative
part of the United States and you're
like, Well, we're just saying let
the addicts go to rehab rather than
prison, why would you oppose that?
But they do, because they view
it as it's not just a compromise,
they view it as fundamentally
immoral to require
something of people.
A place where it gets
even a little more puzzling, I would
say, is where we you start to get
into mental illness.
And this idea
of again offering
some treatment
path rather than
prison for somebody
who has a mental illness
who is acting out in some
way on the street, again
committing some other crime.
It's not just that they
are mentally ill and hurting
nobody, it's that something
happened. They're they're violating
public safety in some way.
And again, you encountered activists
who said offering treatment as an
alternativeis not
the right path forward.
You know, in that, so there's the
argument I had with the ACLU
and the ACLU in California,
and she says,
I says, Well, what if somebody is
defecating you know on the sidewalk?
Shouldn't they be arrested?
And she said, Well, it depends on
what they're doing. And she said,
you know, if it's
if it's a frat guy urinating
on my driveway, then he should be
arrested.
But if it's a poor
homeless person, you know,
then no.
And I was kind of like, Well, but
then like, how are you going to get
them the help that they need or
like, what about enforcing the laws?
I mean, it just got really twisted,
but it can't. That's the that's the
story of victim ideology.
I mean, she just thinks there's some
people that are victims and some
people are not. And if you're a frat
guy, then you're definitely not a
victim. But if you're the homeless
guy, you definitely are victims.
That was the way she described it.
I mean, look, I think there's a
concern that and I share
it, which is that if you
get sentenced
for example, to a psychiatric
hospital, you're in
a psychotic state and you're out of
control and you're sensitive
psychiatric hospital and maybe
you're only sentenced for 90
days or six months in
jail. Go into that institution and
never escape and never get
into kind of, you know, residential
care.
You know, you have some harsh words
in there for thinkers like
Foucau,
Thomas Szasz as
both of whom questioned
the very underpinnings of
psychiatry.
And
I agree that
in some regards, they probably
went too far.
But there does seem to be
the core of something that
we need to be vigilant of, which is
you talk about wanting to expand
the scope of conservatorship, which
is where basically some other entity
takes control of somebodies
decision making, legal decision
making.
We know this can be abused.
Britney Spears was the big
recent example of that.
Is it even possible to balance this
adequately?
Or is it too dangerous
to hand the state more
and more ability to
have conservatorship over
people because they have
a mental illness as the state
defines it?
Yeah. Well, let me let me address
the Britney Spears thing.
I actually had Britney in the book
and she and I and she came out of
the book towards the end because
she's not, you know, the book's
not about me.
She's she's a rich
celebrity. Right?
But but we don't know
that she that her conservatorship
was inappropriate.
We have no evidence for that
whatsoever.
And even if she were to then say
it was inappropriate, that's not
proof of that.
So I think that, you know, in terms
of those proceedings are
confidential. We have not seen the
court proceedings.
We do know that there were some very
strange behaviors
around her and her kids
that may have been related to both
mental illness and drug addiction,
but we just don't know.
I agree. conservatorship is very
radical. There is,
in some cases it's appropriate, but
obviously it should be used in
limited cases.
I mean, I would say that the courts
in California rarely do it, so
it's not like it's being widely used
right now. And so that means that
the people that are getting
conservatorship, it's a pretty
extreme circumstances.
I mean, you gotta remember we have
cases out here where it's like
people will have been in like a car
accident or motorcycle accident
and have brain injuries
and end up drug addicts on the
street and their families can't get
them the care
they need, even though obviously
they had like, you know, obviously a
physical injury that resulted
in them being, you know,
unsheltered and homeless.
There is another alternative, which
is assisted outpatient treatment
that's just a court ordered
psychiatric care for folks.
It's less restrictive
or it's less
total than conservatorship.
It has been focused on
mental illness, but it could also be
used for addiction.
You know, what I would say is, I
mean, look, there's never of course,
there's no.
Of course, it's always going to be
wrong in some way.
There's always going to be some
people that are getting are getting
mistreated by too much state
involvement. And there's going to be
some people that aren't going to be
getting enough.
If you kind of go the Dutch, get
as close as anybody has gotten.
I'm sure you'll find people that
were unjustly hospitalized and
Netherlands and some people
that are that needed more care and
didn't get it.
I will say that I think if you have
the functioning care system that we
don't have, then you're going to
reduce that a lot.
You know, we just find that in
places where the care is better,
there's a lot less resistance to the
care.
And your big picture
idea for
fixing the dysfunction on the
streets is this agency
that you call Cal Psych,
which would override
all the local mental health
departments and funnel both those
with mental illnesses and
drug addictions into a
centralized system.
And you're a critic of what
you call the results of the
neoliberal model of contracting
to non-profits.
But my question about that is
aren't more localized public
private partnerships just
more accountable to communities?
I mean, like, why should anyone
trust a system run by
California state government, which,
after all, did oversee
the system of abuse of insane
asylums of the late 19th
and early 20th
century?
I mean, why would I expect,
you know, something run out of
Sacramento to be cost effective,
humane or accountable?
You have to work with the social
worker, you know, or you have to
work with a cop in this particular
way. But that that needs to occur.
And that's the improvement of
policing in terms of psychiatry.
I'm with you. I mean, there has been
some people that have called for a
return to big asylums.
I think the evidence and basically
what everybody says that has
to live in one of those is that the
residential care is much preferred
to big old asylums.
You know, you have to remember then
those residential care facilities
are going to have to be in people's
communities, and there's usually
very strong NIMBY resistance.
I do think some of that solved by
being able to have those residential
care facilities in
other parts and spread out more
uniformly around the state, not all
concentrated in downtown San
Francisco.
But I do think that's an important
reform that needs to be made and
probably does need a lot of federal
help. The current system is
a kluge in the sense that
you have a bunch of charities,
churches, private health care
providers, rehab
health care providers
that are paid by
taxpayers at the county
at the county level, mostly
to provide care.
Right now, they're not accountable
like they.
They have been struggling for
decades.
One of the most depressing parts of
this research is reading,
you know, Blue Ribbon Commission
reports from the 80s and
90s or early aughts
talking about how there needs to be
more coordination so they can't
coordinate even at the local level.
So part of the problem is
that part of the problem is the
population itself.
It's especially the addict
population is highly transient.
I mean, transient was one of the
words that was used before we
settled in on homelessness on
homeless, but it's a highly
transient population.
If it's a criminal population,
so often they're often escaping
local police jurisdictions that are
after them.
But if they're mentally ill, there's
also a high level of transients.
So, you know, it's just a
huge problem in that sense.
But the other big problem is is
the is the cost and so in
in San Francisco, San Francisco,
Los Angeles is attracting huge
numbers of addicts from around
the region, the state and the
country.
You know, as people on the streets
from Cleveland and West Virginia,
it's very expensive.
I mean, San Francisco just can't do
any services because they can't
provide psychiatric and addiction
care for every addict in America.
It has to be able to move people
places it has to build.
And so you have a physical problem
of we don't have enough homeless
shelters, psychiatric beds,
residential care in San Francisco,
and you never will.
And by the way, I'm arguing for a
super hierarchical,
transparent agency
that does contracts
with these different providers.
So there'll still be a lot of
private sector providers.
I don't think you need to nationalize
the entire sector.
For example, the Dutch,
for example, do a big subcontract
with Salvation Army.
Two thousand Salvation Army
employees work in a contract
for the Dutch government.
It would be a government agency
with a CEO who reports directly
to the governor with like regional
managers who then oversee
caseworkers and contracts.
And I think the power of having a
new agency with new leadership is
you can create a new culture, you
can create an institution and
it can be really high functioning
if it's allowed to kind of rebuild
from scratch as a kind of
skunkworks, rather than having
to somehow try out of reform
these institutions or, God forbid,
coordinate.
I mean, like these are institutions
that just are resistant to any
amount of coordination.
Is there any
hope in your mind that
the healing is going to begin any
time soon?
Are you optimistic about that?
Or do you think that it
still needs to get worse before
it gets better?
I don't think it does have to get
worse before it gets better.
I'm not.
I've always been a proponent of
immiseration theory in general,
including in my in my Marxist
days.
I think that the whole point of
political advocacy is that you can
raise the bottom.
Of our word from addiction
intervention, we are seeing
a significant response in San
Francisco, and I'm happy
to contribute to it to the extent
that we have for the last few
months, we started protesting open
drug dealing in May.
We've organized the California Peace
Coalition with parents of street
addicts, parents of kids killed by
fentanyl with recovering addicts and
community leaders.
It is having an impact.
Just, you know, the book has had a
big impact in San Francisco.
The mayor announced
a crackdown on open drug dealing
in mid-December.
She immediately experienced pushback
from the San Francisco Board of
Supervisors.
She's now getting bureaucratic
pushback, but she's pushing back
against the pushback.
You know, I get a lot of calls from
people all the time with different
kind of views of what's going on.
But I do have hope.
And it did. It did help that Fox
News and the conservative national
news media were pounding away on San
Francisco. I mean, the San Francisco
brand is in deep
trouble and it will be for many
years to come until they fixed it.
I mean, we hear reports of people
from Reykjavik and from Thailand who
are like, Yeah, we were just talking
about because, you know, the bad the
horrible situation in San Francisco
has made international news.
So I do think we have to keep the
pressure on, and I think we need
to praise the politicians from
whatever party they're coming from
when they move in our direction,
even if it's not very far.
Are you bothered by being
characterized as kind
of a tool of the right wing now?
I've read lots of criticisms
along those lines.
We started with the title of your
book that kind of plays into that
somewhat.
I mean, nobody likes being
criticized.
That said, I think it bothers me
less now than it ever has.
Yeah, I mean, I just retweeted
a friend of mine who talked
about how, you know, it's like, you
see, I don't get invited to go on
CNN or MSNBC.
My last book was ignored by the
Times.
This book was was was reviewed,
and an attack from the reviewers
lied about the book, which is
to be expected.
But it also got an Editors Choice
mentioned in the year end review
for the Times I,
after the mayor of San Francisco,
announced a crackdown.
I was invited to finally give a
speech at the Commonwealth Club,
which is sort of our liberal,
you know, high society
club. So
there is a thawing occurring.
I mean, generally, I get attacked
at the exact same moment that
my work is having some impact, so
I kind of remind myself of
that.
You know, and I'm I'm not a right
winger, and I'm not just
demanding, you know, a return to the
drug war, and I'm not just wrapping
things in language, I'm actually
proposing a pretty substantive
new social program.
Apocalypse Never was last year
and that's my book on the environment
and it was just so taboo.
And so I was just such
persona non grata really until now.
Where it is starting to be taken a
little bit more seriously by
liberals, still not as much, I
think, as San Fransicko, but I think
San Fransicko, the ideas
in it are maybe
paradoxically given the title, but
they're actually there are more
palatable to people, to liberal
people when they really consider it.
And then so you know, you've got to
the other day.
My philosophy is sort of like if you
try too hard to
make your ideas palatable, then
you're at risk of corrupting
the ideas themselves.
And so you have to have some faith
in that that the times
will change to catch up with the
ideas.